the Latin region of the world is a very
interesting one for technology I'm
talking today to Gigi Gigi you're from
the the region's FTTH Council but let's
start off by asking you in ftth council
terms what is the Latin region Brian
thank you for that lovely question I
love to explain what lat amis latum is
the conjunction of two words Latin
America and it's a the concert of the
nations that are Latin origin based in
American continent so it embodies Mexico
Central America Spanish and Portuguese
speaking caribbean countries and South
America that is Latin that's really
interesting thank you for explaining
also my pleasure so now we've defined
where it is tell us about how FTTH is
getting on and being deployed across the
range ftth had an original section of
efforts going into trials at the end of
2010 the first countries that were
serious about trials in that period
where Chile Uruguay right and Mexico to
an extent then it got serious starting
in twenty eleven when massive telmex and
Telefonica in Chile and Telefonica in
Brazil and aunt Eleanor white started
actually deploying the first commercial
operations on FTTH so that's how it got
started today if you want to know where
you know how we're doing today boy we
are so proud because you know we have
passed the barrier of 10 million zone
pass which was you know we we ended in
15 millions on past and at the end of
2014 we had close to three million
subscribers so although the penetration
rate may seem of the take rate may seem
low you know it's the early stages of
our technology that is coming definitely
to Latin America to finalize this
concept of where we are at you know we
were following until last year
only eight countries deploying ftth now
we are following 17 countries of a total
of twenty-five in the region so we
expect that all 25 will be active in
FTTH deployment within the next three to
five years and then that time is it
that's amazing now one of those
countries i think is a really
interesting case and that's Uruguay
close to my heart you know I am
originally from Argentina but when I was
a kid I used to spend all my summers
with my family in their beautiful
beaches in Uruguay you why it's a for
3.8 million inhabitants sandwiched
between Brazil and Argentina right and
we call it the jewel of the river
plate's there the president Pepe Mujica
empowered the national carrier until
government-owned and also a monopoly but
empower them to do fiber to the citizen
so you know they have reached 500,000
subscribers at the end of last year in
terms of penetration meaning subscribers
versal total households thanks to until
or why latum has gotten into the
international chart for the first time
in history of the ranking done by the
father to whom council global alliance
and you know why is within the top five
but that's amazing that's great that's
your wife that's great and how about the
work of the council house that
developing Oh kind of busy and very
happy with it I you know I used to be a
professor in the past in my early ages
of engineering and one of our main
activities is training and certification
our mission is to promote the adoption
of FTTH as a universal broadband
bi-directional system for all the
citizenship in the region so our main
activity is training the people
certifying them Retraining them letting
them know best practices and you know of
course we have our conference like all
the council's have and our next
conference if I may say so is in
Santiago Chile just a month away are you
coming I'll try good but in the meantime
thank you very much for talking it was
my pleasure
thank you Brian so now we know what
latum is and we know that great things
are happening there